relieved and finally free after hours of
hiding in toilet stools and under desks
we just closed the doors and then
gunshots were just being spread all over
our own you know from the top I think
they went to the top floor and they
decided spring bullets just when it
reached the ground floor I saw a woman
get shot and then that's when I took the
stairs back through the first floor then
someone actually locked me outside cuz
are not from their office and then we
went to the washrooms we were like seven
people listen come outside the hotel a
friend tried to give reassurances by
cell phone CCTV showed the gunmen
entering the hotel complex before the
attack
within hours Somali based terrorist
group al-shabaab had claimed
responsibility the morning after the
attack Kenya's president gave a defiant
televised address confirming the siege
was over and that all Islamists involved
had been eliminated we have dealt with a
threat decisively and shown our enemies
and the world that we as a country are
ready to deal with any threat to our
nation but many Kenyans remain skeptical
at the government's ability to protect
them we are blaming our internal
security staff because
how did these people get into our
country and we have our security all all
of around this latest deadly assault in
Nairobi shows the Al qaeda-linked group
remains a force for the Kenyan
government to reckon with very
disturbing horrifying scenes there let's
bring in our correspondents LOL nicko
who is joining us from Nairobi Sela
what's the situation right now yes I'm
here at the mortuary that she Roman
watery which is not far away from where
the from well from from where the attack
happened so it's literally a 5-minute
walk from there and as you'll see once
this car passes here there are several
people there's security here there are
there there relatives here waiting for
waiting to see if they can identify
their relatives who form victim to the
to the attack and and just a few minutes
ago the opposition leader I lowered
Engel was also here so it there has been
a huge response here to this to the
attack let's talk a little bit more
about the perpetrators we know that the
Somalia al-shabaab group that they
perpetrated this attack a number of
targets in Kenya in fact over the last
couple of years
tell us a little bit more about them and
their motives yes Bob is a group which
is a militant terrorist group which is
based in Somalia but also has a lot of
pockets in Kenya the borders are very
porous and and so there's there's a back
and forth there's there's definitely a
connection and al-shabaab connection in
Kenya and Kenya Kenya is also known as a
recruiting ground for al-shabaab they
have claimed the attack
we haven't the Kenyan government hasn't
hadn't verified that they've said it's a
terrorist attack but yeah but it was
very complex attack so they with two
explosives at least and and then gunmen
in the building so so so it does sound
one could be likely also Bob as one
might
imagine I mean as we also saw in our
report Kenyans really fed up with this
recurrent threat of Islamic terror in in
the country why is the government or
perhaps you can talk about the
challenges why this organization is not
yet under control yes well I mean it's a
terrorist groups of course it's
difficult to get a terrorist group under
control there are lots of different
pockets of it there in Somalia itself
there are always situations where part
of the web partly regions are under
control of the Somali government and
partly or or foreign security forces
like the Kenyan security forces or the
UN secure the African Union security
sorry and but there are also situations
when al-shabaab takes over so and they
have been able to to target attacks in
mainly in in Kenya and in Somalia and
and yeah although the Kenyan military is
there and Somalia they are apparently
finding it difficult to control the
situation and keep everybody watch this
this terrorist group to know what
they're doing so that Oneko in Nairobi
thank you
you